sinceramente Quando quando quando quando
il look che ho preferito sicuramente
quello di Chiara è la prima cantante che
è uscita sono pazza che c'è ha guardato
tutta la puntata non ce l'ho fatta più
mi sono addormentata è la Cumbia della
noia e poi e poi non lo so guarda Quando
Quando Quando Chi è il tuo preferito in
gara e Mengoni e che canzone Porta
quest'anno Mengoni Non mi ricordo il
titolo Quando quando quando quando
Angelina Mango è la Cumbia della noia e
basta chi voterà questanno Marcella chi
Marcella di te di me Sono pazza perché e
la canzone di giol è interessantissimo
hai capito tutto tutto dirà quando
quando quando piango non mi viene mai in
mente quella lì che Bacio Io bacio tu il
look che ho preferito St mamm Gold
Sibilla ha ricreato un po' il look di
gali per me tu per te e poi per il resto
non ho capito nient'altro un po' fatta
turchina è quello che mi è piaciuto di
più ieri sera sul palco dell'Ariston lei
come si vestirebbe mi metterei un
vestito tutto scolato tanto scolato